Es curioso, cuando conoces a un jefe de estado y preguntas,
"¿Cuál es su recurso natural más valioso?" --
los niños no es lo primero que mencionan.
Y cuando mencionas a los niños,
inmediatamente están de acuerdo contigo.
(Video): Estamos viajando hoy con
el Ministro de Defensa de Colombia,
que es cabeza del ejército y de la policía,
y estamos entregando hoy 650 laptops
a niños
que no tienen televisión, ni teléfono
y han estado en una comunidad
aislada del resto del mundo
durante los últimos 40 años.
La importancia de entregar laptops en esta región
es la de conectar niños que han estado desconectados
debido a las FARC,
la guerrilla que se inició hace 40 años
como un movimiento político y que se convirtió al tráfico de droga.
Hay mil millones de niños en el mundo,
y 50 por ciento de ellos no tienen electricidad
en la casa o en la escuela.
Y en algunos países -- digamos Afganistán --
75 por ciento de las niñas no van a la escuela.
Y no quiero decir que abandonan la escuela
en tercer o cuarto grado -- simplemente nunca van.
Así es que en los tres años
desde que hablé en TED y mostré el prototipo,
esto ha ido desde ser una idea
hasta convertirse en una laptop de verdad.
Tenemos medio millón de laptops hoy en día
en poder de los niños.
Tenemos aproximadamente un cuarto de millón en tránsito
hacia éstos y otros niños,
y hay otro cuarto de millón más
que está siendo ordenado en este momento.
Tenemos entonces, aproximadamente, un millón de laptops.
Esto es menos de lo que predije --
predije de tres a diez millones --
pero sigue siendo una cantidad muy importante.
En Colombia tenemos cerca de 3,000 laptops.
Es el Ministerio de Defensa con quien estamos tranbajando,
no el Ministerio de Educación, porque esto es visto
como un tema de defensa estratégico
desde el punto de vista de liberar estas zonas
que han estado completamente aisladas,
en donde vive la gente donde han provocado, por así decirlo,
40 años de bombardeos y secuestros
y asesinatos.
Y de repente,
los niños tienen laptops interconectadas.
Estos niños han progresado.
El cambio es absolutamente monumental,
porque no solamente es volver a abrir la región,
sino es abrirla al resto del mundo.
Por supuesto, están construyendo carreteras, por supuesto están poniendo teléfonos,
y por supuesto, llegará la televisión.
Pero estos niños de seis a 12 años
están navegando en Internet en español y en su lengua local,
de modo que crecen
con acceso a información,
con una ventana al resto del mundo.
Antes, estaban aislados.
Curiosamente, en otros países,
es el Ministro de Economía quien lo ve
como un motor de crecimiento económico.
Y esté motor dará resultados en 20 años.
No va a pasar, claro, en un año,
pero es un importante y profundo
cambio económico y cultural
que sucede a través de los niños.
31 países en total están participando,
y en el caso de Uruguay,
la mitad de los niños ya tienen laptops,
y para la mitad de 2009,
cada niño en Uruguay tendrá una --
una pequeña laptop verde.
Bueno, ¿cuáles son algunos de los resultados?
Algunos de los resultados
que son comunes a todos los países
incluyen maestros expresando que
nunca habían disfrutado tanto el enseñar
y la comprensión de lectura
medida por terceros -- no por nosotros -- se dispara.
Probablemente lo más importante que observamos
es niños enseñándoles a sus padres.
Ellos son dueños de las laptop. Se las llevan a casa.
Es así que cuando conocí a tres niños de estas escuelas,
que habían viajado todo el día para llegar a Bogotá,
uno de ellos trajo a su madre.
Y el motivo por el que la trajo
es que ese niño de seis años
estaba enseñandole a su madre
a leer y escribir.
Su madre no había terminado la primaria.
Y esto representa una inversión de roles importante,
y es un excelente ejemplo
de los niños como agentes de cambio.
Entonces, para finalizar, la gente dice,
¿Por qué laptops?
Las laptops son un lujo, es como darles iPods. No.
La razón por la que queremos laptos
es que la clave es la educación, no la laptop.
Este es un projecto educativo. No un proyecto de laptops.
Ellos tienen que aprender a aprender. Y entonces, imagínense --
pueden tener, digamos, 100 libros.
En un pueblo tendremos 100 laptops,
cada uno con un juego diferente de 100 libros,
entonces el pueblo tiene repentinamente 10,000 libros.
Nosotros nunca tuvimos 10,000 libros cuando fuimos a la primaria.
Algunas veces la escuela está bajo un árbol,
o en muchos casos, el maestro tiene solamente quinto de primaria,
por lo tanto necesitamos un modo colaborativo de aprendizaje,
no solamente construir más escuelas y entrenar más maestros,
lo cual se tiene que hacer de todas maneras.
Estamos promoviendo nuevamente "Give One, Get One".
El año pasado promovimos un programa "Give One, Get One",
y éste generó más de 100,000 laptops
que pudimos entregar gratis.
Y al ser una laptop sin costo,
podemos ir a países que no pueden pagarla de ninguna manera.
Y eso es exactamente lo que hicimos. Fuimos a Haití,
fuimos a Ruanda, Afganistán,
Etiopía, Mongolia.
Lugares que no son mercados,
sembrándolos con los principios de
saturación, conectividad, bajas edades, etc.
Y de esta manera podemos alcanzar grandes volúmenes.
Así que pensemos de esta manera:
pensemos como si estuviéramos vacunando niños
contra la ignorancia.
Y pensemos que la laptop es la vacuna.
Nunca se vacunan algunos niños.
Se vacunan a todos los niños de un área.